jean jacques rousseau was undoubtedly a
genius who questioned all traditional values
ole life was one t
ing above all he was against was against the m
narchy against the church against the exist
ng state against inequ
lity against traditional child
rearing against marriage and of cours
against the  tech
progress to put it in a modern way one could
say russo was a professional
obstructionist for most of his
life he was then also on the
move or on the run
sometimes he was chased by the church sometimes by
governments of different nations
but all arrest warrants against him
were of no use wustrow wrote that  book
the state treaty of contrast and
with his demand for
democracy prepared the french
revolution and finally
became a pioneer of
ecological thinking through his famous discourses one must not
forget and not enough with that at the
end also founded a revolutionary
ped  agogik, which we know today as
anti-authoritarian education in the
book kosovo in 60 minutes, i try to
work out these core ideas of his work using more than 70 quotations.
i got
the decisive impulse, by the way
, on the way to a friend who
was in prison at the time, refrain from the
newspaper more cows de  france under
an apple tree and in it were competitions from
the académie française
and they wanted to know whether the
people in france are also getting better morally as progress is increasing
everyone wrote yes of
course he said no
precisely because of civilization we are
becoming more and more decadent  and the strangers and
are breaking down more and more and he was,
so to speak, the first philosopher to
set up the theory of alienation so he
says
the beautiful wild screams still roams
through the woods has all his
instincts and is free and modern
man has lost everything he experienced
society experienced in the eyes of
rousseau is right and if so what
can we do about it